Prison Reform is an issue that unites
people from across the political
spectrum it's an amazing thing our whole
nation benefits if former inmates are
able to reenter society as productive
law-abiding citizens President Trump is
seeking common ground on an issue long
championed by the left but many
Democrats objected to a prison reform
bill the house just passed here to tell
us why is congressman doug collins of
georgia who co-sponsored the first-step
act the democrat had came jeffries of
new york congressman collins say for
being here late you do something with a
hood King Jeffrey's but isn't either guy
like pushing impeachment at Trump but
well I can't remember is I thought all
confuses me but that is something people
want more of bipartisan work and yet the
Democrats are kind of all torn up about
this except you know how came and some
others what is it I think what you find
here is when you actually get a
president who's willing to work on
issues when you get a president who's
concerned about the working class who's
concerned about everybody America
putting us first that's when you begin
to reach out and we and my partner
Hakeem Jeffries on this we understand
that you can actually make a difference
in people's lives II know what we're
supposed to be about up here is making
difference in people's lives
giving hope to those who are in sales
right now these are the kind of things
so when you voted against this but if
you're a Democrat you voted against this
bill yesterday you voted to keep ladies
shackled while they're giving birth to
and in prison you voted to not let the
recidivism those who need help to when
they come back out over 90% of our folks
Lauren come back out of prison we want
to make sure that we're doing a good job
spending federal dollars to make sure
that we're putting those away that need
to be locked away like ms-13 they need
to be locked away forever or put away we
need to take those who are going to be
coming back out Society and give them
tools just like the president said to be
productive citizens when they come back
out a second chance at redemption is a
powerful narrative in our literature and
our country's history so you put you
give money to fit 250 million for new
funding for prisoner re-entry programs
we spend a lot of money with recidivism
so you end up saving money if it works
and it and it's but it's dividing the
Democrat Party Kamala Harris against it
Cory Booker against it both of them are
gonna be running for president in 2020
they both want to shore up their left
wing bonafide even though the left was
for this Van Jones said
on CNN today let's watch if you hold out
for everything sometimes you get nothing
and under the Obama administration we
held out for everything and we wound up
with nothing and I think at the end of
the day what we're gonna learn about
this country is that where we fight
where we disagree were supposed to fight
and fight hard but let's not forget
where we agree we're supposed to work
together and work together hard
especially people who don't have a voice
well so he was supporting what he was at
the event supporting the prison reform
bill he's being trashed a tweet today
Oliver Willis on Van Jones van provides
window dressing so racist administration
can point to their black friend without
really doing anything you know it's
amazing what else become on many of
these from the tax on their attacks on
ban like that is it tolerance in their
muse to agree with me what we've
actually become is that when we actually
expressed you just like he said you
fight for the things you believe in but
you find areas of agreement when you
have a group right now the left that are
saying we want more we want more what
they're actually saying is we don't
wanna do anything we like the issue we
like the fact that we were gonna be the
own this issue and not help anybody
there were they're worried about the
black vote turning even 5% more for the
Republic giving them a chance maybe
listening to them they don't want they
don't want that congressman I'm really
glad you're doing what you're doing keep
doing more of it I know this is your
third term in Congress do you want to be
here much longer well as long as we're
doing stuff like it's working with this
president yeah we'll continue thanks so
much